All right, welcome to another Zoom call.
We got a bunch of questions to go through.
Again, another reminder, Addausia for people
who've been with me.
If you have questions between Zoom calls,
make sure you look at our blog and our regular website,
not on our member site, but on our regular website.
And you can search that blog for different topics.
I have at least 400 blog posts or so.
And maybe we've talked about that.
Also, we'll be checking back with the membership site
on a regular basis because we are adding things.
If you're not on the membership site yet,
you're missing out on things.
Make sure you email me to get on there.
You'll see different announcements on that membership site.
And one of the announcements that's new
the last three weeks is we've added another Zoom call
on Mondays at noon with Anne.
And she will go over questions, especially kid as well.
So we've also added a page on genetic reviews.
And I also added some information in the detox protocol.
And how to do, it's in the detox page,
in the detoxification page.
So the detoxification page, I added information
because I've shared this information on multiple Zoom calls
but I have not had it written down.
I added information on what I call the lazy man's way
to do coffee.
And I did some weird amounts when I was doing them.
And I know that there's a proper way to do coffee animals.
And we have that all over our website.
Tons of information on that.
Or I did never do that way, exactly.
So I did the lazy man's way of coffee animals
and I shared that on the detoxification page.
And I've shared that with a lot of you people individually
who have spoken with you because people
that don't do coffee animals typically don't do them
cause it's such a pain to do the brew the coffee
the right way and to, I can't lay down and lay on my side
and do all that.
It's too hard to get up, blah, blah, blah.
And I understand that.
So I share my way how to do an easy way to do coffee animals
where you're just standing in the shower.
You're not laid down, you're not rolling on the side.
You're not doing all those things.
You're just standing in the shower, inserted the tube
in your rectum and try to get as much in
and hold it as long as possible and step out of the shower
and step to the toilet when you have to wait.
So I have to give that detail or that detoxification page.
So if you're not doing top coffee animals
because it's too much of a pain
or you don't feel like you can lay down or anything,
please read that section then.
All right, to our questions.
Dr. V, Dr. V is the breast cancer cucker
who I've interviewed a couple of times
and she's interviewed me a couple of times.
I think a great gal up in Canada.
She referenced a study that she found about
Rishi mushrooms that she should be avoided by people
to with hormone positive cancers.
I've seen that, but I don't necessarily agree
with every study that's out there.
A lot of studies on Rishi and breast cancer
that it's beneficial.
So this says, should I avoid that?
And that's in the medicinal mushrooms.
I'm wondering if there's a Rishi free version.
I don't have a Rishi free version
of the medicinal mushroom powder.
We do have Rishi free versions of mushrooms.
Our turkey tail mushroom turkey tails
probably the most potent for breast cancer.
And our we have our private labeled turkey tail
which is a totally organic turkey tail
great product with no exhibits in it.
Then we just came on with that might be a choice.
How do you increase albumin levels protein absorptions
or albumin and globulin are two proteins
that are measured in a blood test
that's typically called the complete metabolic profile.
And albumin and globulin are often decreased
in cancer patients.
So matter of fact, let's say a person doesn't even know
they have cancer and they go and they just get routine blood work.
And if their albumin and or their globulin is decreased
that is considered one of the few ominous sides in routine blood work.
So in routine blood work, you go and get a CDC
and a complete metabolic panel.
There's nothing in there that's gonna tell you you have cancer.
That's why some people will talk to me
and they go, I can't figure out why I have cancer.
I've been getting regular blood work every year
and it's always perfect.
Well, the reason is that there's nothing in regular blood work
like the CDC or metabolic panel
or even a thyroid panel or most blood work that fall there
unless you're doing a tumor for tests
that's gonna suggest cancer.
So you can have a stage four cancer
it's in a complete normal blood work.
But there are what are called ominous sides in blood work
that should tee off a practitioner like,
there's something going on here, ominous sides for cancer.
One of them is decreased albumin or decreased globulin.
But other one is sharply decreased cholesterol.
So when you have these fats and these proteins
that are produced in the liver that are decreased
that can be a side of cancer.
Now most people think like this person
who asked the question is they'd eat that,
well, should I eat a whole much more protein
because albumin and globulin are proteins
but that's the problem.
They're not absorbing enough protein.
It's really has nothing to do with the amount of protein
that you're eating or you're lack there of absorption of protein.
albumin, the globulin levels of the blood
have to do with liver function.
Not really anything to do with protein absorption
or consumption.
So the treatment for a low levels of albumin
would not be to increase protein per se.
No, you can't increase.
You could take some protein powder or something like that.
As long as your cancer is driven by protein and amino acids.
But really the treatment is to treat the lip.
So in a really ultimately treatment
is to be working on treating the cancer,
which of course if your patient does this,
the city to this right now, you aren't doing that.
So some other things that you can do
for this other than treating the cancer
is going back to our coffee animals.
So go back to this detoxification page.
You're not doing coffee animals.
Start with the lazy man's way of doing coffee animals
and work up from there.
So really supporting liver function is your key.
Supporting liver function is your key.
Also look at the detoxification.
On that detoxification page
you could download my book on the seventh page of detox
that might be helpful this way.
Do we eat our hot packs over your liver?
Some just some other things,
visit the things you could do
and cast your own packs over your liver
could be beneficial as well.
Next question is hyperthermia unit ideal
for some cutaneous lesions that are out of the skin?
So my definition of some cutaneous lesion
is still under the skin.
So I'm not sure I'm answering this question correctly.
But maybe it's so bottom line is
what is the hyperthermia unit good for?
So the hyperthermia unit will raise the temperature
of the tissue down maybe an inch or so.
So if your cancer is deeper than that,
it may not do anything.
So let's say if you have prostate cancer,
should I get a hyperthermia unit?
No, probably not.
If I breast cancer, should I get a hyperthermia unit?
Yeah, maybe, yeah, that might be perfect for that.
Liver cancer, I don't know.
No, we've had patients with,
hey, create a cancer that have had,
have seen phenomenal symptomatic changes in hyperthermia.
The gal who is the researcher from Japan,
who I get the hyperthermia that's front
is spoke to me about a month ago
about a person that she had to,
it's just chronic pain issues.
I can't remember what it was from.
I think it was some horrible on a real,
but on a real accident that it helped with that person.
So if you have a lesion that is a skin lesion
like a skin cancer,
hey, hyperthermia might be great for it.
If you have a lesion that's within an inch of the surface
of the skin, it might be great for it.
The only thing you have to be concerned with with hyperthermia
is if you have an open wound
and because hyperthermia is killing the cancer
by increasing the temperature,
but it can also increase circulation
so you don't want to be just going to watch for bleeding.
But hyperthermia we've been fairly impressed
with the results that people are having
with a spend beneficiary.
Next question, a little bit.
Reading your book, Stop Fighting Cancer,
the Star Tree of Cause, and I found
finding recommendations that seem included
but are not in my program, such as modified such respectively.
Also, say book has a section on tax
all in increasing circulating tumor cells.
I have completed 10 rounds of tax on
carbon platinum treatments
and I have good tumor receptor response.
I have now very focused concern with respect
to circulating tumor cells,
which is not a part of standard care.
And grappling a bit of what to do to continue treating
as if I have high circulating tumor cells.
And what I've already read in your book,
if I were one, if I were to add one thing
for circulating tumor cells to what I'm already doing,
would you recommend modified such respectively,
about what I recommend?
Well, modified such respectively does have some studies
that shows that it can be very beneficial for circulating
tumor cells so you have to say that would be a good thing
to recommend.
Always the concern with anybody is that you don't want
to be taking too many things that are overwhelming in your liver.
The good thing about modified such respect
is it's not something that's going to overwhelm your liver.
So it is something that anybody could take.
It's easy to take if you're already drinking a smoothie,
you control it in your smoothie,
or if the only negative thing is it doesn't dissolve
in water at all.
It'll dissolve and it mixes with your smoothie
if you got other stuff in there, no problem.
But if you're going to take it straight,
you can't put it with water.
It won't dissolve, you'll be very frustrated.
If you put it with a little bit of orange juice,
it dissolves instantly.
So, but if you have a smoothie, you could take it with that.
So yes, you could do that.
At this point, you may not have very many circulating
tumor cells, so you don't really need to be as concerned
about that.
Circulating tumor cells, at least from my understanding,
typically surface at a more early stage.
So if you've got a lot of dyed cells,
you're already, you know, you have less circulating tumor cells.
Also understand that you're using the right
that is helping your body attack,
circulating tumor cells already.
So not everybody needs to directly deal with circulating tumor
cells with something that's modified, so perspective.
But it is something that it's easy to add to anybody's protocol.
And it really has no taste.
I am still balancing hormones after my last big swab
recheck balance is improved, but I have also continued
with chemotherapy, which affects my hormones.
So I'm still having night sweats.
Some nights I am dripping wet with sweat
and hugging my right ball to my chest.
Any concern with right getting wet in this way?
No, because it's the ball.
There's no, we are going to get electrical shocked through that.
If you're having night sweats like this,
you're definitely having normal fluctuations
and it's typically because of a drop in estrogen,
which honestly, that is not a bad thing
when you're dealing with any formal related connections
to your cancer.
If you're ERPR or deep positive,
having night sweats and having like metaposal type symptoms,
know they are very uncomfortable and not fun to deal with.
They are really a side of these plummets and estrogen levels,
which really are kind of what you want.
So it's not necessarily a bad thing.
So we talk about good pain, bad pain in some instances.
Well, this would kind of be one of those good symptoms,
bad symptoms, maybe not a pleasant one,
but not necessarily one that you want to try to treat.
I do coffee animals daily, sometimes up to three times a day,
including a plain water and a constipation.
I lay on my side and hold it as long as I can.
Sometimes it seems like I'm going less than what goes in.
Yes, so let's talk about that a little bit too.
I've had people say, oh my gosh,
I did the coffee and I couldn't,
I didn't even have to avoid anything.
Oh my gosh, I've had people that put in two cups of coffee
into the rectum and then they didn't have anything to avoid.
My comment to that is make sure you're not dehydrated.
So if you have any amount of dehydration,
you're going to absorb that water and that caffeine
in your rectum and in your lower colon,
you'll absorb it because you're dehydrated
and then you're going to have anything to avoid out.
So make sure that everyone, let's continue.
And I have a full gut feeling bloated like there,
really is fluid there, higher up in my intestines.
Is it possible actually retained fluid in my guts
or more likely that this is inflammation, feels similar?
Yeah, you can be retained fluid in your gut
and make sure if you are, if you're old,
so you're saying you do coffee out of us three times a day,
I really am concerned about this last piece
of the first sentence for constipation.
So if you're having constipation issues
then that is a little bit of a concern.
I would think I would add some other things
to make sure that I'm having a bowel movement
and I feel like I'm really emptied by bottles.
Sometimes if you've got some heart impactions
in your mouth, you could have the coffee and it would go up
and then go around those impactions
and then you're holding water above an impaction
that is not good for you.
So go back to my seven phases of detox book
and think about things like our phase six assist
which is the Cape Allo product.
250 milligrams of Cape Allo adding that to magnesium
before you go to bed.
If I ever feel like I'm just not avoiding the way I should be
avoiding, I'll take one of those with maybe two or three
of the magnet clear before I go to bed
in a large glass of water that I just cleaned
myself out the next day.
So that's my concern with this question.
Last paragraph, I avoid the most the animal water
with some residue but avoiding much less than
when my guts were healthy and free chemo.
So I'm not sure I'm avoiding enough actual waste.
Yeah, that's my concern too.
And if you've got waste in there,
it's just could become nasty and your body
is just poisoning itself.
So I would look at that.
What I call, phase six, making sure
that you're getting it over the world.
Chat question came in about hyperthermia.
My breast cancer protocol says I tested very beneficial
for using it over the liver.
Yes, if the liver is deeper in my body,
can you help me understand the benefit of using it
and other things?
So like I said, maybe I wasn't clear
that typically the liver, part of your liver
is under your right rib cage, lower rib cage.
And then part of it is closer to the surface.
Your lower lobes and your liver are closer to the surface.
Amy about an inch deep dependent on how large of a person
you are.
And I said, we used the biggest reason why we used
the hyperthermia when we had people come to the office
was over the liver because it really helped get things moving
in the liver.
And we've had people, even though I've said that technically,
I think the heat, the increase in temperature,
the cancer killing increase in temperature,
maybe up to over 102 degrees Fahrenheit,
only goes down about an inch with the hyperthermia.
We've had people with pancreatic cancer,
which the pancreas is even deeper than the liver
have phenomenal results with the hyperthermia.
So it might not raise the temperature in the liver
up to 102 degrees,
but you still increase the temperature closer to the surface.
And it causes some circulation
and it can help with liver detoxification
so it's can be very beneficial that way.
So I'd convince the hyperthermia could be beneficial
literally for everybody,
but don't think it's gonna necessarily kill cancer cells
in a prostate gland which is much deeper.
It's probably not gonna kill cancer cells that deep,
but it's still helping in the liver.
I've noticed I have to go to the master a lot.
So opposite question here, especially last month,
sometimes the master three to five times.
I've only 120 pounds and five seven,
is there a vitamin I may be taking too many up?
So yes, so what will cause this?
So you can look at the detoxification book
that things like Cape Allo products or magnesium.
So you're not taking Cape Allo,
which is the Super Allo 250 or what we call the phase six assist
or some gut motility products.
But the biggest, the most common thing that people are taking
that will increase gut motility,
that you realize that it does is magnesium.
So if you're taking a lot of magnesium
because you've got leg cramps and things like that,
well, magnesium is also gonna loosen your stool.
So many people are deficient in magnesium
and they're taking magnesium
and the way you know you got enough magnesium
is you'll dump excess magnesium
in the gut which will draw water
so you're still so that may be the issue.
So I don't find it to look at your clinical,
what else you're taking.
But certainly that can be a possibility.
But do remember that the normal stool
that will be a healthy habit for a person
is that you are having all movements
three to five times a day.
That would be healthy if you feel like you're,
if you have diarrhea, now that's a different story.
You're losing your fluid, you're not getting absorbed.
But if you have solid stools and you're avoiding
three to five times a day, I don't see that as a negative.
That's a positive.
You aren't detoxifying well.
You're not having too high of a intestinal transit time,
which is how you become toxic.
So chat question coming up.
I have a theraside 360 infrared soda.
How hot does it have to get an order for it to affect cancer?
Typically, we set those at 140 degrees.
Sometimes you start out less than that.
But typically the zip-up infrared sodas
you set it at 140 degrees.
There's no, with the sodas, remember,
so the benefits of the sodas is to really help
with detoxification.
So that you're in there sweating
and that you're getting rid of toxins through the skin
and you're bypassing the liver
and you're taking pressure off the kidneys and liver.
How much are you really raising core body temperature
when you're doing a soda?
That's questionable.
It's hard to detect whether you could take your
temperature under your tongue with a thermometer
and then get in the soda, take the temperature a little bit.
Maybe it'll raise it a little bit,
but is it just a temperature?
The tongue isn't your core body temperature.
It is hard to really get a proper analysis on that.
So typically, if you're really going to kill cancer
in your body, in your person has ERPR
to negative cancer, assume in the breast,
are you really raising the core temperature of the breast?
I don't know.
You technically, to kill cancer,
so you have to raise that temperature at that site
up to 102 to 105 degrees.
So how much cancer do you get in the soda?
Next question.
Does it matter how large your students are?
Yes, it no.
One of the signs of colon or colorectal cancer
is that your stools are getting theater
because you have a mass of your colon.
So typically, you got a pencil like a stool instead
of a larger stool, but a lot of things could change stool habits
and a lot of things could change your stool size.
So don't become overly technical about that,
or overly worried unless you have some major changes
in your stool that persists.
Next question.
Sauna, how long?
Well, typically people start with a sauna to tolerance.
Many times when people start using a sauna,
they can only do it for five minutes
and they feel like they got to get out
to feel good, blah, blah, blah.
It's good to start with anything you start at small
and you work up.
Goal is to work up to, theoretically,
the goal is to work up to 30 minutes
and you could do that every day.
Personally, when I did a lot of saunas,
which I certainly don't know the summertime,
but I was doing a lot of saunas.
I really couldn't go or 20, 25 minutes.
I just started to go through a craze
and don't have to get out.
But I was sweating like a pig too.
So a lot of times when people start saunas,
they don't sweat very well.
That's not a good side.
But the longer they do it, then they start sweating.
I tend to, a lot of people tend to sweat right away.
The whole idea is to sweat.
Next question.
If it's fine to have a bowl with three to five times a day,
does it matter if each stool is very small?
No, it will be very small
unless you're eating a ton of food.
So, but again, the whole idea,
more frequently available,
which is that you have a shorter intestinal transit time.
So the your food that you eat is stayed in your bowel
for a lesser amount of time.
Of course, there's balance there
because if you eat something that goes right through you
and you have diarrhea, you're running to the toilet,
well, then you're not absorbing anything of anything you're eating.
You're gonna lose weight.
You're gonna not get your calories.
And of course, that's a bad thing.
But you also don't want to be voided cord in your stool
that you ate a week ago.
And that's first time you saw a cord in your stool.
That's way too long of a intestinal transit time
when you are definitely absorbing bad estrogen
and all sorts of bad things
that your liver's been trying to get rid of
the little time that you are just killing yourself.
So you're much better off having more frequent smaller
bowel amount more frequently through the day,
for sure.
It's much healthier.
We did a couple of just,
okay, we're gonna be after I did this.
So I gotta address these two.
Recent that I heard of Ozone treatment for bladder cancer.
Don't remember you mentioned this in your book.
This process requires a catheter to put Ozone here
into the bladder.
Also Ozone pumped to the rectum
to it in addition to coffee enemas.
What research have you found
and do you believe it's worth a ton in the night?
Well, Ozone therapy has been shown to be beneficial
in a lot of things.
A friend who's or ER doctor who does some illegal stuff
on the side that injects Ozone into joids for people
because it could be really beneficial to help increase
joint fluid production for damaged hips
and all sorts of stuff.
This person also does Ozone in sulfation,
which is how you get Ozone up your rectum.
I have had it heard about people do it
for their bladder as well.
By take on Ozone with cancer is that Ozone is O3,
which is an unstable molecule,
which will freely get an O negative molecule off.
O2 is stable and it freely gives it off
and what's the benefit of that?
Well, it could be very pathological
that O negative ion could be pathological
to different pathogens.
So if you have Lyme disease, Ozone therapy
could be very beneficial for that.
It could kill mold.
It could kill mold in your house.
That's why you use an Ozone generator as an air purifier.
But I don't know, I know there are some doctors
who use it for cancer,
but it's certainly not the only thing that they're doing.
I just don't, for me, I just have never been
really into Ozone for cancer for that reason
of just having a hard time understanding
why an oxygen ion would kill a cancer cell.
It wouldn't kill regular cells,
but I don't know why it would kill a cancer cell
so I just, unless the cancer is like fungal in nature
or there's a fungal component to it,
I'm not a big fan of Ozone therapy.
So cancer.
Another question that came in with the member site
before I get to these chat questions.
And what are you about glutathione?
I have ER positive, PR positive
occur to negative breast cancer.
Is it helpful and safe for me to use specifically
like with liposomal glutathione?
So glutathione is your major detox.
It's a piece of your phase 2 detoxification in your liver
but it's a major intracellular detoxifier.
It's a major intracellular antioxidant.
So you certainly cannot use glutathione
if you're doing chemotherapy
because chemotherapy kills cancer through oxidation
and you're using it in antioxidants.
You can't use it if you're doing chemotherapy
but it's big in the function of medicine community
and it can be very beneficial.
The benefits there is study that just read last week
about using liposomal glutathione
to help get rid of mercury toxicity
and just amazing results of liposomal glutathione.
The problem with glutathione historically
is that glutathione in the sources that we've had
in the past was just not absorbable at all.
So it was just not even more taking.
We used to do glutathione in nebulizers
which was very good for the lungs.
That wasn't for cancer patients
so that was years ago we used to do that
for autoimmune conditions.
However, liposomal glutathione with that
has come out now is just a phenomenal tool
for helping with detoxification.
So really the purpose of using glutathione for cancer
is not to kill the cancer.
It's to help with detoxification of other things
that could be dragging your body down
and hindering your body's ability to kill the cancer.
So I don't really see it as a huge, as a big negative.
You just want to look at why you're using the glutathione
if you're helping with detoxification.
Question of the chat regarding sweating in the sauna.
I have an infrared sauna and spent an hour per day
on average and always well hydrated
and sweat profusely.
Who are my hands and feet?
However, my hands and feet I notice
you're not sweat in the sauna.
They normally do, but outside, any thoughts.
I don't know.
I haven't noticed whether my hands and feet sweat
in the sauna either.
You do have, you know, you definitely have more.
So you have different types of sweat glands understand.
So you have the saline glands that are on the majority
of your skin.
And then you have different glands, these oily glands
that are underneath your armpits and between your legs.
And think of the purpose of those,
how I got gave those to us.
So you sweat differently with oil underneath your skin
and underneath your armpits and between your legs,
because if you're runnyed and you're hot,
you need lubrication there.
But the purpose of sweating in the rest of your body
is to cool your body because when water is on the outside
of your body, it has to evaporate
and the process of evaporation decreases
the surface temperature 22 degrees.
But the purpose of sweating also is to get your toxins
that are in the tissue too.
So you will get rid of toxins of the tissue.
I don't know why you don't sweat through your hands
and beat it.
I have to think about that a little bit.
I don't know if there is a physiological reason there
or you just have more fluid in your, the rest of your tissues.
I'd like to break a coffee concentrate on vacation with me.
Would that be possible?
Oh, yes, as long as you keep it sealed.
And as long as, you know, you make sure that it doesn't spoil.
So you can keep it refrigerated or in a cooler
where it's keeping cold.
You, you know, you certainly don't want it to mold
or anything like that, but that's definitely possible.
Can cancer cells use glutathione to their own benefit?
Possibly, yes.
So that's possibility that you do have to be careful of.
Cancer that's one theory and I do talk about that in the book.
I think about cancer cells using glutathione
to help detoxify some process that you're using.
And then we have more app to happen if you're using an oxidative
nutrient to kill cancer like protocell
is an oxidizing nutrient
or if you're using chemotherapy,
you certainly don't want to use glutathione
because it's such a strong hit to the opposite.
Is there a difference between cancer cells and tumor cells?
Yes and no, it doesn't how you're defining it.
So some of the medical definitions are a little bit gray
because of over time, they've been changed.
So over time, so back in the 30s and 40s and 50s,
cancer and tumor were synonymous terms.
Technically, now they're not as synonymous
though still doctors and even research papers
use them synonymous, they've been technically a cancer
is considered a malignant disease
meaning the cancer is cells that are spreading
and replicating at a higher rate
where a tumor is defined as cells that are abnormal
but are not at a high-stated replication.
So that's like the difference between a malignant cancer
and a benign tumor.
So most writings about the subject
will use those adjectives before the noun
in order to give greater definition
because it is the two terms that are used
so synonymously in the past.
Coffee concentration, thank you.
What ratio might I use for the coffee and water
to make the concentration?
I don't know if you can certainly do a two-to-one ratio
where you just have to add water.
You know, as let's say you take a pint out
and you have to add a pint here,
a cup out, you have to add a cup.
Whatever, however you can concentrate it
to be able to create the,
to make it easiest for you to be traveling.
What have you observed the body to do when one is nearing
the end of the black sand process
my last test got to five days ago, barely any paid
much less yellow stuff coming forward
and hoping that near the end.
Yeah, so what you'll notice
is that the next, when you're at the end of the process,
you'll put the black sand on and then it's like,
you know, you know, what it has been doing each time.
And now it's your, you're gonna be like,
this isn't doing anything.
Then this isn't doing anything.
Three days later, it's kind of falling off
and then on that black sand was kind of falling off
and it's, it's, it's to do anything.
You may, because you've done this so much,
try to reapply it and see if you can get anything else.
You certainly don't want to.
I think it's an error to let it heal up and then reapply it.
You have it closest to any left cancer cells as possible.
You want to continue to reapply it.
Maybe two, three times until it's like, okay,
this is not doing anything.
And it's, you'd notice even when you're applying
that, you know, the second or third time
that it's healing, it's starting to heal up.
And you're noticing that there's,
you're sharp to see a little scar tissue that is taking place.
It's because the black sand is doing anything
because the black sand will react to healthy cells
that will only react to tumor cells.
So you'll, you'll know that, okay.
I've reached everything that I could possibly reach.
Hopefully, I've gotten everything out.
I have bird feeders outside my window
and I've kind of addicted to birds.
So like, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven bird feeders out here.
Yesterday morning, there was nine blue jays.
Blue jays must be ground feeders
because most of them were on the ground,
a couple of more of the different feeders.
There was one of the feeders that was healed.
The other ones was that you get up there
and shovel food to us as he was literally
with his beak to shoveling food out of, you know, bird seed
out of my feeder, out of the ground.
And they're all eating, it was just hilarious.
But it's like, okay, that's where all my bird seed is going.
So that goes through a lot of bird seed
but a lot of them very pretty birds now.
So I wish I could show a team.
All right, any other questions?
Just to remind her, if you haven't jumped out in the Mondays
to Zoom call at noon central time and details
around the members of the site under the Zoom calls
for you to do so, they're also recorded
and posted up there for you as well.
And she will go over the questions.
And if you don't feel as if you have an adequate answer,
I will go over it too, if you don't feel,
I give you an adequate answer which I don't most of the time.
Just to apologize, I just do the best I can.
So, all right, I will be praying for all of you.
Have a great afternoon, the rest of the afternoon.
Enjoy the sunshine.
Hopefully it's sunny where you are.
I'll be praying for all of you and I'll see you next week.